Robert
I need you to use your Walker and come
down the driveway to us okay
please come down the driveway to us we
can't come to you
just come slowly down the middle of the
driveway
okay so you're still gonna be long cover
let her lethal I'm so sorry you're still
gonna be lethal hey you still got
cuffing hey you still got my little
lethal hey just pick up a long cover
right here with the deal okay
Jackson yeah give that up bud
thank you
come on Robert
hey oh
go into the middle of the driveway
Robert
into the middle and come to me
he doesn't want to go past the pot
okay
he's gonna fall off of that
yep is that a gun
let's go to him before he falls
all units
turn all your radios down
okay like coach have coms
okay
come on Robert keep coming
where do you want them to preferably
right at the gate man if if or bring
them all the way up bring him all the
way out if he wants to come all the way
out let's bring him all the way out
see anybody see what's in the basket it
looks like that just looks like a bag
and then like a plastic
look like it almost looks like a
tupperware container okay the big dog
looks okay but I don't I don't trust him
yet
I don't trust that little dog in the
backyard yet
hey I'm good just hold you're doing
great Robert keep coming bud
a no return yeah
you got a what
hey is that a back brace you're wearing
this looks like papers now in the Box
we will as soon as you come to us okay I
need you out of the yard
you're doing great though okay keep
coming
hey when we move to app
uh don't forget to pick the house up
when you got y'all have to communicate
don't forget to pick the house up
he might not be able to go to the ground
so he might just be standing out here
Jackson
yeah he's not going to go to the ground
your call we'll just take him around
Robert I need you out in front of the
car okay just come out like towards this
crack here in the
front of the car you're doing great bud
keep coming
don't forget there's a shed to the right
with an Open Door
hey Cooper as soon as you get done with
this path here
four total to see there's two on the
other side
yeah we'll get you a water Robert keep
coming Bud go do your right thumb go to
your right son
all right listen
we're gonna be good with you as long as
you're good with us okay
hands behind your back
hey can somebody toss me one more set
please you're good stay still Robert
I know we're gonna we're gonna help you
walk okay okay let's put him in Bobby's
car for now y'all can y'all handle that
and I'll help with them
all right I'll form up with y'all you
got four